that was midnight suns and now we're
moving on to the wonderful world of
cuphead the delicious last course and
can you believe it we're only a couple
weeks away from playing the delicious
last course dlc you see how they did
that for cuphead joining me now is maya
maldenhauer from studio mdhr so first of
all maya it's really coming it's really
coming june 30th on all major platforms
we are thrilled well i'm so thrilled too
that uh i think all the fans can't
believe that this is here and i've been
lucky enough to play this actually on my
steam deck uh last week you guys gave me
a copy this
i can't people are not going to be ready
for how amazing this looks and the
backgrounds and what you guys have done
i feel like you've you've amped up
obviously the gameplay it's difficult as
we would expect but the visual look you
guys have taken it even to the next
level so i think was possible yeah we
absolutely did i couldn't pinpoint one
thing that we're proud of in this
because we really honed our craft took
everything to the next level from
animation the backgrounds the music
gameplay design um and of course a new
playable character miss chalice i'm very
proud of her
chalice is fun to play as and even
though this is a dlc it feels like it's
its own game inside of cuphead in many
ways it is it is definitely yeah you
just get on the island and there you are
off to this new uh new territory which
is yeah it's our biggest island yet
super-sized bosses lots of secrets to
discover um don't let any rock go
unturned yes and lots of challenge ahead
well i know you brought i i know you
want you don't want people to
necessarily have too much spoiled about
the game but you brought a little
something a little something yeah it's a
brand new gameplay footage of one of our
new bosses mortimer freeze it takes
place in an icy arena
and features some of my personal
favorite attacks and transformations we
hope everyone enjoys it all right let's
check it out cuphead the delicious last
course next wild
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now if you want even more cuphead and
who doesn't tomorrow we will show you an
exclusive look at season two of the
cuphead show when i co-host netflix's
geeked week which will include new show
and game announcements it streams at 10
am pacific 1 pm eastern
and